la ville de rio de janeiro est toujours
aussi spectaculaire mais quand on s'en
approche quelque chose ne va pas les
rues sont vides il fait plus de 26
degrés il fait beau normalement les
plages sont remplies demande la grande
promenade côtière est une fourmilière
même chose dans la mégalopole de san
paolo c'est l'heure de pointe
normalement les artères sont
congestionnés les brésiliens commence à
sentir le danger de l'épidémie et
prennent les choses en main il se
résigne à s'isoler et en ont vu d'autres
ils ont assez bien maîtriser l'épidémie
récente de sica quel contraste avec
l'attitude de leur président le
populiste jaillir ball sonar ou le
trempe tropicale qui continuent à
afficher son scepticisme au sujet de
lakovic 19 le voici en direct sur son
compte facebook
ce matin à brasilia la sortie du palais
présidentiel il parle du coronavirus
avec ses partisans
mais rien sur les précautions à prendre
il garde quand même un peu plus ses
distances qui a quelques jours il y a
une semaine
il disait qu'il fallait protéger le
gagne pain des ménages au soc faire dans
la famille l'ofs réservables et qu'il
fallait retourner à la normale dans mon
cas disait-il comme je suis un athlète
car si j'étais affecté ça m'inquiéterait
pas vraiment qu'ils sont tirés guère
plus qu'une petite gripette ou un petit
rhume voici la réaction des brésiliens
un concert de casseroles pour 10 de
contestation
la situation est plus problématique dans
les favelas il est difficile de s'isoler
de se protéger
le gouvernement a réduit le montant de
la bolsa familia programme qui sert à
nourrir les plus pauvres alors les ong
essaie de prendre le relais celle-ci
norris dix à vingt mille familles par
semaine mais c'est insuffisant
les causes il ya 15 millions de
personnes en pauvreté extrême et 30
millions dans des emplois informels qui
paie très peu en l'absence des forces de
l'ordre ce sont les bandes criminelles
qui tente de faire respecter l'isolément
social dans les favelas il faut
d'exemple présidentielle ce sont des
membres de la société civile comme leur
rappeur mc beal qui conseille aux gens
de se protéger face au vétéran caucase a
fait du star dominé mais rodez mollo
non jean michel le patron du canada
montréal